[Musique]
bonjour philippe buquet vous êtes le
directeur de ce fameux espace des arts
nous sommes ce matin pour un 9h50 un peu
particulier une scène nationale et puis
un endroit qui a été complètement
relifté c'est le moins qu'on puisse dire
bonjour oui effectivement c'est le
projet de plusieurs années et deux
années finalement de travaux presque
deux années un peu moins et à un endroit
majestueux au départ que l'on a
effectivement rénovée et qui est un
grand théâtre public incroyable comme
les spectateurs peuvent le voir au
pourront le voir enfin on n'est pas fier
philippe on se dit bon l'espace des arts
de chalon sur saône qui était déjà
exceptionnel quand même pour une petite
ville provinciale pardonnez moi mais
quand on pense bourgogne franche comté
on pense pas forcément tout de suite
chalon sur saône pourquoi ces travaux
finalement alors c'est vrai en même
temps l'ambition culturelle à chalon est
pas tout à fait nouvelle elles datent
déjà de d'une quarantaine d'années par
le conservatoire par l'espace des arts
par chalon dans la rue
donc il ya une base très solide et
l'espace des arts a une particularité
quand même c'est d'avoir des volumes
très importants aux 1500 mètres carrés
qui sont aussi une force et c'est une
machine théâtrale artistique qui comme
toutes ces machines et quand on se pose
la question de la rénovation c'est soit
passé moi l'expression
on prend là me milliers ont l'art
hambourg soit on fait quelque chose un
peu plus fort et on n'en fait pas une
machine de guerre parce que c'est pas la
guerre mais en tout cas pour des défis
artistiques et pour que le public soit
dans accueillis dans les meilleures
conditions
dites moi cette momie que vous avez
rembourré je reprends votre exposition à
philippe c'est vous qui l'avez dit
qu'est ce qui a changé
là on a vu l'escalier l'escalier il
existait déjà il est classé cet escalier
autour de nous on va le découvrir tout
au long cours de cette matinée
ensemble il ya beaucoup de choses qui
ont évolué rencontrera d'ailleurs tout à
l'heure l'architecte aurait
effectivement beaucoup de choses
l'escalier et très beau c'est un
escalier de verre qui est inscrit au
patrimoine du xxème siècle donc c'est
effectivement quelque chose qui est trop
de protéger préserver néanmoins on a
quand même pu travailler autour à côté
au dessus ou en dessous
voilà on fait attention à ce qui est
vraiment classe et on fait attention au
patrimoine et en même temps on est là
pour redonner du souffle et donner une
ambition architecturale contemporaine au
bâtiment une ambition vous en avez une
nationale parce que on dit l'espace des
arts scène nationale
perso je comprends pas tout à fait ce
que ça veut dire expliqué mois alors il
ya un cahier des charges qui veut dire
que l'ambition et nationale la création
et première l'attention à l'art
contemporain est une chose très
importante art contemporain ça veut dire
danse musique théâtre etc toutes
disciplines confondues
et cette pluridisciplinarité n'est pas
forcément l'objet par exemple d'un
centre dramatique on ne fait que du
théâtre ou d'un centre chorégraphique on
ne fait que de la danse
justement qui a vous me parlez de danse
on va les retrouver l'ami clément sa
mission vous l'avez compris ce matin les
loin d'être impossible pour notre agent
mister clémence et d'aller dans ses
coulisses et nous allons y aller
ensemble ce matin ici depuis l'espace
des arts scènes nationales à champs sur
saône avec votre complicité philippe est
avec vous aussi pour découvrir notamment
une danseuse mon avis ça va être un
grand moment que vous allez nous
préparer
clément confiants ou en tout cas en
effet pascal je suis avec satchie noro
alors vous êtes l'artiste qui va ouvrir
le bal un petit peu de cette
inauguration là ce soir à 21 heures 30
sur le parvis
vous allez proposer votre spectacle
origami avant d'en parler on se fait
quoi d'être là pour l'inauguration d'une
pas d'une nouvelle salle mais d'une
bande jouissif on va dire du nouvel
espace des arts ça fait plaisir
évidemment c'est un trias mans puis de
savoir qu'on fait partie ou silhol de de
l'ouverture aussi au public de cette
salle
surtout que ça va être un spectacle qui
va être offert au public aux chalonnais
qui on voit revenir c'est bien ça il a
été pensé comme ça aussi pour ainsi un
spectacle pour l'espace public et pour
permettre aussi à des publics qui ne
rentrent pas dans les théâtres qui
n'osent pas rentrer de pouvoir en
profiter
c'est finalement le leitmotiv un peu de
cette émission c'est de dire qu'il faut
rentrer dans les lieux culturels mais
c'est peut-être grâce à des artistes
comme vous
qui vous mettait sur les parvis et qui
permettait aux gens de franchir ce pas
ce que je vous propose satchi c'est
qu'on regarde quelques secondes des
images d'origami ce spectacle on regarde
quelques secondes et on s'en parle tout
de suite regardé
[Musique]
comment est ce que vous avez imaginé ce
spectacle origami quel message vous
voulez faire passer
alors d'abord il a été imaginé avec un
constructeur
donc ces deux écritures croisées une
écriture de danse et une écriture
d'architecturé de scénographie mobile
oui parce que c'est un container un peu
spécial oui c'est un container que
sylvain a pensé comme un pliage
d'origami
il l'a découpée en trois morceaux et
avec ces trois morceaux il crée des
origamis c'est un container vivant c'est
un container vivant et c'est vraiment un
duo entre une danseuse et un container
non alors l'origami forcément faut le
dire c'est un petit peu un image ou un
hommage aussi à votre culture vous êtes
franco japonaise a donc finalement c'est
un spectacle sur vous sur quoique non
c'est pas sûr sur moi c'est par rapport
à cet objet aussi du container qui est
un objet de deux voyages que tonnes
l'objet qui transitent dans le monde
entier et dans un contexte économique qu
on n'approuve pas toujours et c'était
une façon de sortir en conteneurs de son
marché pour pour en faire un objet de
poésie c'est ça s'éteint c'est vraiment
le symbole de la que la société de
consommation de masse le comté vers
reims à voyage à travers le monde
mais vous du coup vous vous en servez et
du coup c'est très impressionnant
cette ses arabesques que ces figures que
vous faites
bravo vous venez du ballet classique
vous oui je suis danseuse classique à
l'origine j'étais à l'opéra de berlin et
puis j'ai très très vite bifurqué vers
la danse l'improvisation et puis les
arts du cirque
un peu plus tard du coup c'est vrai que
c'est un spectacle qu'on imagine très
bien pour l'inauguration du nouvel
espace des arts c'est à la fois
l'hommage à la danse éternelle et puis à
la con et à quelque chose de beaucoup
plus contemporain c'est c'est comme ça
que vous l'avez conçus ou wii puis c'est
un espace aussi c'est à la fois c'est
une scénographie mobile qui voyagent
dans différents territoires qui
s'entraînent y des différentes mémoires
des territoires qu'elle traverse et
c'est une manière aussi partager avec le
public un objet qu'il connaît et de le
la de le transformer avec de laisser
imaginer d'autres possibles alors ça
fait maintenant près de 130 date que
vous tournez avec origami un peu partout
dans le monde
du coup vous le jouez à cet espace
désert cette salle a rien à envier aux
autres grandes salles européennes j'ai
l'impression oignons elle est magnifique
bon on va donc inciter les gens à se
rendre ce soir à 21h30 assister en
direct à origami devant le parvis de
l'espace des arts j'ai envie de vous
dire allez bientôt cause animale merci
beaucoup celles ci n'auront voilà
c'était à vous parce qu'elle jouera la
parole merci clément grand moment qu'on
vivra évidemment ce soir on parlera
d'ici la fin de cette émission du
programme très chargé qui nous attend
durant finalement ces trois journées en
plus le beau temps est au rendez vous
dans ce lieu magique c'est bien toutes
les planètes sont alignées philippe
j'espère il faut pour passer trois jours
donc ça démarre très bien on est
évidemment très heureux il ya le côté un
peu protocole de l'inauguration
mais à côté de ça et en parallèle il y à
l'ensemble des artistes qui sont là qui
sont évidemment une force et c'est eux
qui donnent vie à cette maison justement
les artistes que vous avez
particulièrement soignée tout à l'heure
nous avons démarré cette émission rother
vous l'avez vu avec de supers deux
images qui domine
chalon sur saône on est à 9 étages au
dessus de chaussée où nous nous trouvons
près de cet escalier majestueux
là bas vous avez fait une maison pour
artistes surprenante
oui c'est même formidable enfin on
espérait que ce serait bien c'est
beaucoup mieux encore que ce qu'on
rêvait dans la mesure où à la fois c'est
une maison pour les artistes puisque il
ya six appartements six studios de
résidence et c'est très important
puisqu'on est une maison de production
donc ça va avec
à partir du moment où les artistes sont
en répétition chez nous c'est bien
qu'ils puissent habiter à côté et puis
il ya cet endroit connexes qui est un
lieu là aussi un peu plus ri
disciplinaire et qui est un point de vue
absolument incroyable sur le territoire
et la ville philippe on va pas se le
cacher vous avez voulu soigner les
artistes aussi le public que nous sommes
et tous les publics ici parce que c'est
pluridisciplinaire vous l'avez dit ce
qui est important à savoir aussi c'est
que la salle pour ceux qui sont habitués
à l'espace des arts scène nationale ici
à achères ans personne a
considérablement évolué on découvrira
d'ici quelques minutes aussi avec l'ami
clément alors les trois salles en fait
il ya la grande la moyenne et la petite
la très grande salle et la salle moyenne
qui s'appelle le petit espace ont évolué
avec des parallélismes dans le fond à
savoir sur le plan de l'accueil du
public
on a amélioré la pente d'une manière
importante ce qui fait que la visibilité
est bien meilleur on a changé toute la
ciergerie ce qui fait que le confort
évidemment est meilleur on a créé une
sorte de meilleure circulation entre le
plateau et le public
et puis bien sûr côté technique et
coulisses on a amélioré l'ensemble dire
tout le côté c'est nos techniques qui
est là vraiment pour eux la
contemporanéité technologique des
spectacles et puis l'ensemble des
circulations les loges etc
philippe buquet en valais dans quelques
minutes justement dans une de ses trois
seuls dans la plus petite avec l'ami
clément pour se rendre compte de ces
quelques nouveautés mais des nouveautés
architectural il y en a beaucoup
d'autres alors ça serait très
prétentieux franchement de vous à moi
dc 10 heures 40 environ de pouvoir tout
vous dire sur l'espace des arts le mieux
c'est de venir ici pendant ces trois
jours il va faire beau c'est festif
il ya plein de choses gratuites en plus
beaucoup d'animations mais vraiment le
premier regard que l'on porte quand on
entre on se rend compte que le bois est
très présent le béton le vert c'est le
tiercé dans l'ordre
alors c'est une volonté puisque à
l'origine on était dans une architecture
à c'est comment dire brutaliste c'est à
dire sur le minéral le vert lapierre le
béton donc c'était une époque étaient
inscrits effectivement celle des années
50 60 et c est le bois via un petit peu
adoucir et dans la mesure où il y avait
des dalles qui ont été cassés on pouvait
inséré d'autres éléments d'autres
matières qui sont en harmonie totale
évidemment
et en accord bien sûr aussi avec les
bêtes l'architecte des bâtiments de
france puisque le bâtiment étant classés
on a une certaine liberté
mais on fait pas non plus entièrement ce
qu'on veut en fait pas n'importe quoi
bien évidemment on l'aura compris vous
parlez d'architectes on ira voir un
l'architecte qui a travaillé sur ce
projet vous avez été le chercher en
belgique pourquoi vous n'arriviez pas à
trouver en france l'architecte pour
pouvoir rentrer dans le budget et en
belgique et en france puisqu'ils sont
deux pierres et blink et mathieu
berthelot est effectivement dans la
rencontre qu'on a mise en place avec un
ensemble des équipes d'architectes
ils nous ont séduits et pierre nous a
séduits par un discours qui était un peu
différent de ce qu'on peut comprendre on
n'avait pas un gros budget vraiment pour
faire l'ensemble des travaux parce que
le territoire il ya l'aide de l'état de
la région du conseil général c'est très
important mais en même temps on est dans
un territoire à l'économie assez modeste
et notre ami belge puisque c est devenu
notre ami nous a dit attendez nous en
belgique on est habitué et avec ce que
vous avez on va même vous en faire plus
alors ça ça a séduit tout le monde quand
même
vous savez quoi votre ami va devenir
notre ami parce qu'on va aller le
retrouver dans quelques minutes ensemble
ici pour 9h50 en bourgogne franche comté
dans cet espace des arts nouvelle scène
à challans personnes totalement relooké
et philippe mais je lui ai promis
d'abord on va laisser la place à la mi
clément qui va nous faire découvrir
quelques unes de ses nouvelles pépites
si je se dire à découvrir ici l'espace
des arts rendez vous dans la petite
salle clément j'ai l'impression que ça
se prépare pour de jolies spectacle et
oui parce qu'elle en effet on se trouve
sur la scène du petit espace avec alexis
moati en pleine répétition
le spectacle c'est ce soir c'est
toujours un peu spécial les dernières
heures avant le début de votre première
représentation comment vous vous sentez
vous et vos comédiens on est fatigué cd
drôle de période parce que
on a une énergie de fin de marathon donc
on sent que ça approche et en même temps
en même temps il ya la fatigue mais il
ya l'adrénaline qui commence à monter
voilà on sent là en espion la scène
c'est juste magnifique
comment est-ce qu'on pourrait expliquer
les téléspectateurs voient le décor
comment expliquer votre offre c'est un
huis clos familial vous dire ça ou pas
si vous voulez c'est une dégustation à
l'aveuglé sur le même endroit à travers
des différentes époques
voilà il ya des mois il ya des des
archives de choses j'ai des souvenirs il
ya des choses cassé brisé
c'est ça en fait le décor c'est la
maison familiale qui a explosé puisque
l'histoire d'emma avec des enfants qui
étaient des enfants de gens qui ont
tenté de faire la révolution aux états
unis et qui ont été qui ont posé des
bombes donc l'explosion un peu la
matrice du spectacle l'endroit est quand
même génial pour créer une oeuvre non il
ya tout ce qu'il faut ici
ah oui il ya tout ce qu'il faut et des
projecteurs et des gradins il ya peu et
ça pourrait être des mauvais projecteurs
et des gradins un peu moche ça vient
d'être refait donc tant mieux donc
tendance et bien non
mais vont tendre ça vous vous
connaissiez l'ancien espace d art qu'est
ce que vous pensez de cette nouvelle
structure du coup en tant que homme de
théâtre
alors moi là je suis je regarde et je
suis sur le plateau donc j'ai les deux
positions il me semble que le rapport
scène salle est bon il est même meilleur
qu'avant puisque le gradin est beaucoup
plus pentue il ya plus de hauteur donc
donc voilà après je pense que à chaque
fois qu'on découvre une nouvelle salle
on envoie toujours avec les premiers qui
commence à travailler dans les choses à
améliorer les imperfections des choses
comme ça mais sinon la base quel rapport
scène salle pour nous et bon l'histoire
retiendra que c'est votre compagnie
votre oeuf qui auront essuyé les plaques
les plâtres pardon essuyé les plâtres
pendant trois semaines de présence ici
alexis moati on va regarder un extrait
d' happy birthday sam
on croise les doigts pour la première
merci on regarde un extrait le nombre de
pauvres est pourvu du crédit en disant
c'est moi qui convaincra le nombre de
feux exigences à la baisse à chaque fois
mais pourquoi pourquoi que j'avais rien
mais tout le monde sait que travers
mégalomanie puéril face à leurs rivaux
pouvoir la bourgeoisie rex voici
conditions c'est clair pour quels
conseils vous pouvez avoir comme
héritage d'une mère dément complété par
son propre nombril qu'elle laissait
l'histoire de l'édition et lui veulent
c'est la 2ème à albert l'attendait hutin
r - arrêt je pense vraiment que c'est le
jour de lecture qui se dit sans être
comme basile chèrement
un tout petit extrait du spectacle qui
sera joué ce soir ici même à l'espace
des arts de chalon sur saône scène
nationale on l'a dit un ces trois jours
de fête ses 3 jours de rencontres 3
jours de découverte et trois jours aussi
peut-être pour visiter ce lieu dont vous
êtes en quelque sorte l'origine vous qu
est un des deux architectes venus
belgique on disait tout à l'heure avec
philippe pour réaliser ce projet ça vous
fait quoi là d'assister à l'accouchement
tout à l'heure je vouvoyais regarder la
dent dans les premières heures
je vous sentez très très attentif en
fait il ya un moment qui est
exceptionnel pour des architectes et
quentin lieux et créer et réaliser
surtout puisque l'on passe de
l'imaginaire qu'on a pu avoir l'esprit
d'un ensemble de partage de discussion à
la réalité tangible
donc le moment majeur c'est quand les
publics un rythme quand le lieu est
réellement habité puisque c'est à ça
qu'on travaille en fait il ya un autre
moment très important forcément c c'est
le choix c'est la décision c'est
remporter l'appel d'offres c'est
répondre à un cahier des charges
philippe a été dit rectifie vous a donné
quoi tient comme comme direction il a
été directeur et ça c'est sûr c'est à
dire il a une idée claire ce qui permet
de brême vraiment travailler ça veut pas
dire qu'il disait faites ceci sur le
plan spatial
il y est voilà quels sont mes besoins
voilà les besoins d'une équipe il a
d'ailleurs ouvert un dialogue avec
l'ensemble de l'équipe qui est une
particularité de ceux ci puisque c'était
pas vrai qu'on couvre en fait il fallait
proposer une méthode de travail et c'est
la méthode qui a non seulement la
méthode qui a séduit je pense mais aussi
la manière de fonctionner avec une
équipe et fait ressurgir du passé d'un
lieu qui préexiste à nouveau sens quoi
pour toute une ville
justement vous parlez de passer vous
philippe vous le savez ça fait 16 ans
que vous êtes ici le patron de l'espace
des arts à chalon sur saône michel vous
saviez que
cet espace des arts avait été inauguré
en 1971 à l'époque ce n'était pas un
espace d are here exacte d'une maison de
la culture qui a d'ailleurs eu une
histoire rocambolesque et on avait
d'ailleurs comment dirais-je à
l'historien associés au projet pour
déterrer tous les trésors il a
d'ailleurs trouvé les mâles de pessoa
derrière une porte de garage
il a retrouvé l'ensemble des plans des
maquettes des douze années de travail
qui ont été nécessaires pour concevoir
et réaliser ce bâtiment oui on va ouvrir
le placard archives d'ici quelques
secondes et souvent vous savez dans dans
les placards ya des pépites des trésors
à l'époque je ne vous cache pas que la
télé était en noir et blanc voilà la
jouer franco on n'était pas encore dans
l'espace des arts mais vraiment dans la
maison de la culture de châlon sur saône
va faire un petit retour en arrière un
petit flash back et puis nous revenons
ici en 2018 pour ce beau week end du
mois de septembre pour cette
inauguration de l'espace des arts allait
nous sommes en 1971 magie la télévision
par petits groupes les chalonnais se
présentent au hall de leur union à la
coupure pour en découvrir les
possibilités vers fos comme celle de
caen damien de bourges
elle possède des locaux destinés aux
rencontres permanentes salle de réunion
de conférences cafétaria mais aussi des
locaux destinés à recevoir les
différentes formes de cultures et de nos
spectacles troisième système est un
système de courants d'air si on peut
dire ce sont des volets qui sont au
dessus de la scène et qui aspire l'air à
ce moment là les spectateurs pour en
dégager durant cette période inaugurale
qui prend fin demain tous les émulateurs
se relaie pour montrer leur nouveau
buteur les instruments de travail qui
seront ceux des comédiens cinéastes
musiciens ou artisans de toute autre
forme d'art apparu d'amples qu'il
fallait constituer une équipe aussi
diverses que possible aussi
contradictoires que possible entre ces
éléments pour s'adresser à une
population qui est elle même très
diverses et très contradictoires de
quelle manière sera défini l'esprit des
activités vous
entrée l'esprit vous savez il n'ya qu'un
problème à nos yeux c'est d'arriver à
susciter des rencontres entre les
membres de cette population à laquelle
nous nous adressons 1971 et retour en
2008 c'est ça la magie de la télé on a
beau être un architecte magicien c'est
quand même assez compliqué d'être dans
un lieu comme ça on parlait de
l'escalier tout à l'heure avec philippe
un escalier classé qu'en fait-on pour
faire les choses qui sont classés
justement dans ce nouvel nouvel édifice
il ya deux potentiels d'une part on
observe là les caractéristiques du lieu
c'est à dire en transformant un lieu on
en crée un lieu unique
on a des opportunités uniques d'ailleurs
on est actuellement à l'instant présent
dans un espace qui n'existait pas qui
était sous une sous une sous un plateau
sous un couvent donc là complètement
ouvert pour dilater ce qu'on appelle la
rotonde donc on a créé en découpant un
plancher on a créé un espace de sueur
auteur oui on a fait la même chose pour
les accueils puisque le bâtiment avait
été conçu au départ ou sur un
rez-de-chaussée sur un plateau de la
chaussée mais a été élevé pour y placer
quelques voitures en dessous juste avant
l'ouverture je vais dire comme ça juste
avant le chantier est donc on a
redécoupé les choses pour permettre d
accès et le rapport à la vidéo au parvis
en fait donc ça c'est une manière de
réinterpréter l'histoire pierre quand on
entend un architecte on se dit oh là là
mais c'est extrêmement simple on découpe
on refait on remonte etc
sauf qu'il ya un moment il ya le voisin
gaye et à philippe qui tient les cordons
de la bourse et qui se dit au secours le
coûte 2 des travaux ici
philippe ça n'a pas été considérables
contrairement à ce qu'on peut penser ce
qui est des chalonnais qui sont avec
nous il ya la bourgogne franche comté
qui s'est beaucoup investi dans dans cet
endroit particulier et l'argent c'est
important aujourd'hui c'est très
important d'autant que c'est de l'argent
public alors les cordons de la bourse et
le grand chalon qui les tient qu'il est
qu il étonné puisque c'est le grand
chalon qui est le maître d'ouvragé un
sur sur l'ensemble du bâtiment
je reviens sur le coup c'est face à
l'architecte des coupures vertes et
heroes mais je me dis mais ça va coûter
une fortune cette affaire lors la
question je dirais que c'est eux c'est
une question d'état d'esprit est bien
moins de 1000 euros pour pour qu'on
parle clair on va jouer clair ce matin
on est à moins de 1000 euros le mètre
carré quand même qu'on est à 805 euros
du mètre carré
aujourd'hui 800 505 euros c'est à dire
qu'on est au entre le tiers et le quart
d'un équipement culturel oui voilà sas à
brasles voilà là parce qu'on a utilisé
des outils et des méthodes et des
arbitrages de l'envelope comme on
appelle ça qui permettent alors de faire
des choix vraiment fondamentaux découper
un plancher ça coûte pas grand chose
mais qu'est ce que ça apporte
c'est énorme et donc les grandes idées
ici c'est à la fois de permettez accueil
par rapport à la ville c'est à la fois
de renforcer la lacc le rapport salle
scène dans les salles d'offrir un
meilleur service au public
la troisième chose s'est créé une
symbolique qui est la servante qu'on a
placé sur sur le sommet de la cage de
scène et qui n'existe nulle part en
europe donc avec des moyens spécifiques
on est arrivé à donner une ambition très
grande ou projet tout en s'appuyant sur
l'histoire malgré tout vous avez eu
quand même quelques contraintes là tout
paraît trop facile même si on peut voir
quand même leurs travers des quelques
belles images qui sont faites ici ce
matin en couleur qui reste encore un
petit coup de peinture par ci un petit
coup de peinture par là on est au bout
les contraintes
oui je parle peut-être pas facilement
sous la contrainte en gros le rapport à
tous les objectifs qu'on s'était fixés
on a traduit ses objectifs au mieux de
ce qu'on pouvait il ya le jeu santé ce
matin le plaisir de l'équipe de l'espace
des arts de retrouver ses murs et donc
je crois qu'effectivement que les
contraintes et les souffrances qu'ils
ont qui sont générés aussi par un
travail architectural et et constructif
on le voit dans l'exposition du
l'excellent photographe la souffrance
des hommes et donc je pense que ça va se
dépasser au dès le moment où le
spectacle la clape va se faire justement
vous parlez du photographe benjamin
shelly on va le retrouver d'ici quelques
minutes pour découvrir cette expo photo
moi je vous remercie d'avoir pris
quelques minutes sur votre précieux
temps parce que ce qu'on n'a pas vu
évidemment c'est que depuis que vous
êtes là ce matin vous regardé partout
vous aspecté tout vous notez tout un
petit cahier bon c'est pas encore tout à
fait tout à fait finie mais pour ce week
end ça devrait bien se passer quand même
hein vous garantissez tout tout tout
devrait aller
tout va les bons tout va les filles vous
êtes rassurés je suis rassuré je veux
juste ajouter quand même qu' il ya une
question d'état d'esprit à la fois par
rapport au respect du lieu qui avait
conçu l'architecte initial daniel petit
et on le voit les gens le verront
il ya quand même aussi une forme
d'humilité il n'y a pas de luxe dans ce
qui a été rajouté
oui j'avais deux choix on peut faire
cher ou faire en se disant bon on a
cinquante budget on va le faire rentrer
à coups de bottes mais ça va rentrer
dans le budget c'est très important
allez philippe ans le dit entre nous on
n'est pas au grand palais voilà et on
est avec du béton avec du bois avec du
verre avec le talent de deux architectes
1 belge 1 français à découvrir aussi en
photo
d'ici quelques minutes avec benjamin
shelly mais est d'abord on va les
retrouver notre trublion qui est avec
nous et ce matin là mais l'ami clément
qui est avec une costumière que vous
devez connaître philippe une costumière
que chez vous depuis bien avant vous
d'ailleurs un une magnifique figure de
l'espace des arts voilà je pense qu'elle
doit en avoir des anecdotes
merci encore monsieur l'architecte pour
ce bâtiment formidable ou celui votre
confrère et
merci à vous d'être avec nous ce matin
et est de continuer je l'espère de
passer à un moment sympathique en tout
cas nous on va tout faire pour il nous
reste encore quelques minutes ensemble
ah oui effectivement pascal en aidant
les coulisses juste à côté de la
répétition de happy birthday ça marche
avec pierre l'un des comédiens savent à
quelques heures de la première vous vous
êtes break mais a toujours du stress du
trac mais ça va avouer ça va on est prêt
je pensais je crois que la personne à
côté vous la connaissez bien oui chantal
ouais c'est pas votre premier spectacle
ici du coup forcément la costumière est
toujours la même c'est toujours la même
et on apprécie vraiment de l'avoir avec
nous ce qu elle est formidable et en
plus d'une humeur très stable et ça
rassure tout le monde
elle est super les micros chante abadie
donc chantal sazy pied
ouais ça fait plaisir ça oui bon vous
êtes un peu la gardienne du temple 1 on
va pas dire puisque ça se fait pas de le
dire vous êtes là depuis un moment et
j'ai 26 ans époux tout est prêt pour ce
spectacle
tout sera prêt et oui quelque chose
quelques petites affaires à ranger
installés mais tout sera prêt pour ce
soir est ce qu'on a toujours la même
fébrilité avant une première d'un
spectacle
oui bien sûr mais après moi je suis en
coulisse mois voit pas c'est pierre et
ses camarades
qu'est ce qui vous a plu pour travailler
sur ce spectacle happy birthday sam au
niveau de la recherche estime en terre
comment vous avez travaillé alors j'ai
travaillé avec aude qui est la
costumière d'alexis moati voilà on se
connaît
et un petit peu aussi parce qu'on a
travaillé déjà plusieurs fois ensemble
voilà on a fabriqué des choses
en attenant à transformer d'autres voilà
tout finalement à chaque spectacle c'est
vous préférez quoi vous plutôt le
contemporain ou vraiment le classique
vous aimez quoi molière j'ai moitié
j'aime bien j'aime bien les deux voilà
mais c'est différent à chaque fois
je préfère être en coulisses que sur le
plateau vous avez des beaux souvenirs en
oui bien sûr les belles créations avec
des acteurs connus comme lambert wilson
ouaip idée de philippe decouflé on
m'avait dit que vous avez estime que le
couple est alors n'a pas fait de
costumes de decouflé on les a accueilli
plusieurs plusieurs fois d'accord et là
vous venez de me ruiner directement en
direct mais ses paroles je ne veux pas
mal parce que votre sourire vaut toutes
les erreurs du monde voilà parce qu'elle
en était avec chantal et bien on va vous
laisser pas ce que pierre doit retourner
pour sa répétition et nous on se
retrouve tout à l'heure
[Musique]
finalisé en tout cas que chez lipp que
toute l'équipe de l'espace des arts a pu
voir apprécier puis qu'ils ont fini par
sélectionner sa dû être mais ça doit
être compliqué pour eux j'imagine
j'imagine
dites moi il ya forcément des anecdotes
quand comme ça on rencontre autant de
personnes sur un chantier colossal
vous qui avez parcouru le monde il ya
des petites choses qui vous ont
émerveillé sur cette histoire sur ce
chantier ici à l'espace des arts de
chalon sur saône valley principalement
le travail de ces gens qui travaillait
justement avec le béton est ce qu'on
voit ici d'approché vous approchez vous
on va regarder ensemble
effectivement on voit un travail assez
surprenants comme vous dites ça vous a
émerveillé c'est à dire tout autant pas
la difficulté aussi tu parles aspect
esthétique
il ya une forme de ballet la rapidité
d'exécution parce que bien évidemment ça
prend vite et il faut aller vite et il
ya tout un tout une démarche et rien
n'est laissé au hasard
mais en même temps tout autant dans la
difficulté où on voit vraiment le
travail de l'homme et et l'aspect très
pénible des choses en même temps quelque
chose de très beau qu'on peut voir
notamment ma place
dans cette image là mais aussi que vous
pouvez retrouvez vous nous fait reculer
dites moi benjamin céline on voulait
avancer salle en avance dans la vie vous
avez raison pour refuser en tout cas
vous avez aussi celle ci où on voit
vraiment une plante de synchronisation
et on est très proche de la danse
ah oui pour avoir fait aussi beaucoup de
photos de danse ont évidemment on est
très projet à danse rien tout est
millimétré en fait même si ça paraît du
gros oeuvre
ça reste un travail qui est extrêmement
fins extrêmement délicat et puis avec
des gens qui sont armés d'un très grand
professionnalisme non c'est pas tout à
fait là dans ce qu'on a pu voir tout à
l'heure avec l'ami clément inquiète dans
les coulisses avec nous ici dans
l'espace désert pour nous faire vivre en
fait les meilleurs endroits où on ne
peut pas rentrer est-ce que vous
benjamin shelly photographe officiel de
l'espace des arts de chalon sur saône
pendant ces 24 mois de travaux
vous avez vu toutes les portes ouvertes
est ce que philippe vous à ouvrir tout
l'espace d affranchir burt white où j'ai
pu aller partout sur les toits les
sous-sols voyez je peux aller partout à
tous les moments tous les instants avec
votre oeil de photographe forcément vous
avez vu des choses qui ne sont peut-être
pas sur ce mur il y avait avec une seule
photo à retenir de ces 24 mois des
poupées à chalon sur saône
je dirais celle des toits celle des
toits quand il faisait très chaud cet
été enfin non l'été dernier où il
explique en degrés ça a été un travail
tout autant éprouvant et en même temps
merveilleux parce qu'on était ont dominé
toute la ville et et en même temps avec
quelque chose de très dur de 2 très
pénible et voilà une façon de communier
avec ses hommes
avec cette chaleur je crois que oui c
était un très grand maman le fameux er
nov
on a ouvert l'émission d'ailleurs au 9e
étage dans cette maison d'artistes
unique en france moi je n'ai pas peur de
le dire
lorsqu'on a quand même de quoi être fier
en bourgogne france comté on le disait
tout à l'heure avec philippe ça peut
paraître surprenant d'avoir un endroit
comme ça dans une petite ville de
province mais le pari a été réussi
oui c'est merveilleux et puis c'est un
lieu qui donne le vertige dans tous les
sens du terme
c'est vrai c'est vrai alors vous l'avez
constaté en vie les premières heures de
ce week end inaugural ensemble avec vous
sur france 3 il ya bien sûr beaucoup
d'autres événements encore à passer
ensemble nous reste quelques minutes moi
je vais vous libérer le tranquillement
benjamin shelly en précisant que si on
vous google is comme on dit si on va
faire un petit tour sur internet se rend
compte que ce garçon là qu est avec nous
ce matin pour votre matinale a fait
aussi de très très belles photos dans le
monde entier dans plein d'endroits
exceptionnel et voilà on est super fiers
de vous avoir eu dans jamais un chili
merci merci à vous vous restez aussi
avec nous vos quêtes là sur france 3 le
point complet du programme peut être
après un petit plongeon dans les
coulisses avec clément chez manu clément
je bégaie un petit peu ce matin pour
découvrir les améliorations apportées
dans le quotidien de ceux qui
travaillent ici c'est avoue clément a
tout de suite
alors écoutez pascal avec
jean-christophe le caméraman derrière
son steadicam on n'a pas pu s'empêcher
au plaisir de vous montrer le grand
espace de l'espace des arts c'est à dire
la salle principale 850 places alors
nous on a l'habitude à france 3 de
couvrir les lieux de culture en
bourgogne franche comté cette salle elle
est juste fantastique moi sincèrement ça
ne peut pas me ment péché de me lancer
dans une petite tirade juste pour tester
on va voir comment on reste plus vivre
sans cette infamie ça sonne bien ça pour
sonner ça sonne ça vaille manuel et
qu'ils ont pensé qu est ce que ça sonne
bien bas il ya un peu de problèmes 1
mais sinon on va dire que c'est bon d'un
point de vue technique en tout cas le
progrès il est présent après deux ans et
demi de travaux ici voilà bah
techniquement
on nous a donné un outil plutôt
performant voilà
l'essentiel c'est ça la nouvelle
visibilité le nouveau gradins la
suppression du rideau de fer qui nous
permet de faire des spectacles carrément
au pied des spectateurs c'est une
demande de contemporaine on va dire
c'est ça en fait vous avez devant vous
vraiment un exemple parfait de ce que
doit être le les lieux de culture en
2018 quoi c'est déjà très fonctionnel
ben voilà il faut les temps de montage
se réduisent et c'est faut être le plus
performant possible et là on a bien
progressé on est justement faut qu'on
explique là vous êtes au train de monter
parce que ce soir du coup il annonce par
l'orchestré national de lyon qui se
produit et on voit le montage vous allez
pouvoir monter là dans quelques minutes
l'emplacement pour les 85 musiciens
la modularité c'est ça qui est le coeur
de ce métier c'est pouvoir très très
rapidement changer les scènes mais c'est
exactement ça on passe d'un orchestre à
une pièce de théâtre un spectacle de
danse voilà donc qu'il faut façon à
chaque représentation tout est
strictement démonter et ranger
voilà donc il faut que ce soit comme
vous dites le plus fonctionnel possible
vous avez douté un petit peu quand on
est responsable technique comme ça on se
dit mais c'est pas possible
deux ans et demi de travaux vous êtes
dit on va y arriver ou pas parce que
c'est vraiment impressionnant
les travaux qui ont été effectués ici
mais je vous cache pas que là on est
dans la dernière ligne droite et la
partie scénique et scénographique on va
dire on était plus ou moins confiants
enfin un état relativement confiant
jeudi après c'est surtout la ce bâtiment
où il ya des coups sûrs qu'ils t'ont bon
allez plus que quelques heures de
travail et puis on y sera dense espace
des arts nouvelle génération tout à fait
je pense que ça donne envie aux gens en
tout cas de venir voir des spectacles
voilà pascal on se retrouve dans
quelques minutes je vous laisse avec vos
invités à tout de suite
grand moment à vivre ce matin vous
l'avez compris nous sommes
télétransporté à l'extérieur fait un peu
frais ce matin et je pense que ce soir
ce sera beaucoup plus chaud c'est un
week end inaugural philippe piquet qui
est particulier qui est exceptionnel à
l'image de cette nouvelle espèce d art
ici à chalon sur saône
c'est une grande fête trois jours c'est
pas un festival mais enfin il y en a
partout à savoir que comme on a rénové
trois salles vous doit y avoir de l'art
et des artistes dans les trois salles
on a aussi ce par hui donc on a aussi
sur ce parvis une manifestation
artistique dans la rotonde également
dans tous les espaces les spectateurs
pourront voir des spectacles ou gratuits
ou payants du théâtre de la danse de la
musique aux grands espaces
cc oui c'est énorme une exposition des
visites un bas je me suis même laissé
dire qu'il y allait avoir un ciné brunch
qu'est ce que c'est que ça voilà donc
aujourd'hui c'est du théâtre
d'abord au studio noir avec benoît
lambert qui est bien connue directeur du
centre dramatique de dijon petite
parenthèse le studio noir c'est quoi
c'est une salle de 70 places qui était
un volume un espace et qui là est fixé
avec une technique de salles aux grands
espaces à 21h la grande soirée de
l'orchestré national de lyon sans
musiciens c'est un blockbuster à 19
heures quelque chose qui est très
important pour nous puisque nous sommes
un lieu de création et de production
donc une création d'un metteur en scène
qui s'appelle alexis moati sur un texte
d'un jeune auteur qui s'appelle quentin
laugier ce qu'on a vu tout à l'heure
avec clément voilà et je vais pas
raconter dévoilé le spectacle c'est une
histoire d'aujourd'hui
forte de famille sur ce qu'on transmet
ou ce qu on ne transmet pas donc pour
quatre soirs à l'espace des arts
aujourd'hui très bien qu'on n'oublie pas
quand même que tout au long de l'année
et un programme qui est particulièrement
riche et surtout très variés voilà quand
même je ne dois pas oublier satchie noro
qui est une danseuse japonaise et qui se
bat c'est une bataille avec un taureau
énorme qui est un container même
plusieurs containers ça c'est ce soir
ici et demain soir et puis
je peux raconter programme de samedi
mais bien sûr mais bien on a parlé du
sivi brunch un tout à l'heure on s'est
dit mort devait être signé prochainement
ce samedi il ya une chose importante
aussi qui s'appelle extension qui est en
plus petit une séquence de 20 minutes
d'un grand spectacle qui a conclu notre
présence au théâtre du port nord autour
du hip hop avec des danseurs
professionnels qui ont encadré le tout
et une quarantaine de danseurs amateurs
donc on en fait une forme offertes au
public en grande salle à 18h30 demain
samedi
et puis alors il se peut que j'oublie
des choses puisque oui oui on va
certainement oublié le mieux c'est
d'aller faire un petit tour sur le net
pour retrouve évidemment toutes les
infos concernant ce week end très très
festif
ça commence aujourd'hui 1 c'est un vrai
vsd servait vendredi samedi dimanche
voilà d'ailleurs le dimanche survivre
sur ce fameux si les brunchs on en a on
y va un tout petit peu parlé allez on y
va c'est quoi le temps c'est quelque
chose d'assez particulier je pense de
très sympathique et ouverte puisque ça
touche les familles brunch ça veut dire
effectivement pour le dimanche que s'est
ouvert à partir grosso modo de 10 heures
du matin 10h 10h30 jusque vers 16h donc
il ya à manger s'est organisé pour tout
ce qui est restauration brunch par le
restaurant des canailles qui est situé
sur l'île saint laurent qui accompagne
en fait quoi
du cinéma et notamment les films de
michel ocelot qui est bien connu et on a
la chance d'avoir en avant première son
nouveau film qui s'appelle jeu pas
écorché le nom dire il y à paris je
prends en tout cas plusieurs films dans
la journée
on entre on sort on se restaure sur
place c'est pour les familles il fera
beau dimanche on peut être dedans dehors
donc je pense que c'est un dimanche
génial super alors il y en a plein qui
vont me dire oui ok c'est très gentil
ce que dit philippe mais moi je peux pas
vendredi samedi dimanche rassurez vous
ça reste ouvert tout au long de l'année
avec une programmation riche et variée
on va faire tout le catalogue mais moi
j'aimerais que vous me disiez les yeux
dans les yeux philippe comment on fait
pour avoir une programmation aussi
éclectique parce que c'est assez
surprenant vous êtes capable de faire le
grand écart facial
on dirait pas vous voir mais alors il
surprenant oui il ya des choses qui sont
très très différentes alors par contre
il ya un critère sur lequel on lâche
rien c'est la qualité ça c'est sûr que
il s'agit de toucher le maximum de gens
possible de toucher les familles de
toucher le jeune public de toucher des
habitués par contre en terme de qualité
en lâche rien quelle que soit la
discipline
donc on peut toucher des grandes
compagnies contemporaine en danse ou des
choses qui sont un peu plus rugueuse
mais qui sont importantes de présenter
parce que c'est la jeune création en
théâtre on peut toucher des des artistes
comme molière avec jean-pierre vincent
ou alexis moati quentin logique qui sont
des plus jeunes
et c'est donc dans tous les domaines
c'est effectivement de courir vers un
prisme qui va disons 'peut-être vers les
360 degrés mais toujours à un vrai
niveau
tout simplement parce qu'on considère
que les gens peuvent recevoir des choses
même exigeante
une vraie fierté culturelle de la région
à l'image d'un autre endroit que vous
devez connaître forcément c'est le
conservatoire du grand chalon et j'ai
envie de vous montrer quelque chose de
particulier il est devenu récemment le
premier établissement de france à gré
pour la préparation à l'entrée dans
l'enseignement supérieur de la musique
en mettre aussi un petit peu de musique
pour terminer vous vous restez philippe
je pense que clément de rejoindre impôts
pour la fin allez on y va dans ce
conservatoire
vous avez vu qu' on a ouvert un
dispositif là pour les classes
préparatoires l'enseignement supérieur
c'est tout frais le directeur du
conservatoire de chalon commence juste à
diffuser l'info chaque année à la fin de
leur cursus en cpie enseignement
professionnel initial
certains jeunes tentent les concours
d'entrée dans les établissements
supérieurs
désormais il dit seront préparés ici de
manière spécifique dans des classes
dédiées à cet effet
jusqu'à maintenant on n'avait pas la
chance d'avoir cette nouveauté
alors j'ai pas encore au courant de tout
mais ce qu'on a dit ça l'est pour me
permettre de préparer ses entrées aux
grandes écoles et c'est une chance pour
nous tous
pour ces jeunes ce nouvel agrément a
déjà une incidence sur leur statut des
étudiants vont pouvoir bénéficier enfin
d'un statut étudiant alors bizarrement
dans les conservatoires à par le
conservatoire supérieur de paris et
celui de lyon deux seuls en france
les élèves des conservatoires étaient
élèves et non pas étudiant donc n'avait
pas les bénéfices des bourses
d'enseignement supérieur etc
nous voici maintenant chez les profs du
département jazz pour eux qui accompagne
déjà les jeunes vers l'enseignement
supérieur l'agrément est plus une
reconnaissance qu'un bouleversement
en fait c'est un travail qu'on faisait
déjà et le fait d'avoir cet agrément
finalement ça ça atteste que qu' on est
dans ce dans ce parcours là est dans
cette dynamique là en fait donc c'est
pas une pour nous finalement c'est pas
une c'est pas une nouveauté c'est plutôt
la reconnaissance qu'on fait du bon
boulot pour nous c'est un nouveau
dispositif où on va accentuer le côté un
peu préparation aux concours mais on va
garder la spécificité de chalon qui est
quand même la créativité donc le
challenge pour nous c'est comment on
peut bachelot t100 bachoter pas question
donc de fabriquer des bêtes à concours
reconnu pour son excellence ce
conservatoire va ainsi continuer à
cultiver ce qui fait sa richesse et son
attrait à savoir un brassage des publics
et des pratiques depuis les enfants des
crèches jusqu'aux retraités des talents
qui vont forcément aussi éclore dans ce
nouvel espace des arts de chalon sur
saône n'y a pas que le grand
conservatoire du grand chalon
philippe alors des conservatoires sont
des amis et des partenaires j'ai
beaucoup de respect pour eux si vous
êtes partenaires et bien sûr on
travaille de manière très proche ce
serait idiot de ne pas penser les choses
comme ça naturellement donc
effectivement cette maison est aussi un
révélateur de talents c'est pour ça que
l'on travaille beaucoup avec des jeunes
artistes et donc quelquefois des jeunes
qui sont passés par le conservatoire
voilà c'est une maison qui a aussi cette
fonction la féline joue un tout petit
peu pardon je bégaie parce que je sais
qu'il nous reste très peu de temps et il
ya clément justement qui nous a rejoints
c'est un travail d'équipé il était avec
nous ce matin pour nous faire vivre les
coulisses clément vous avez été surpris
je vous ai vu je me suis fait mûr
hâtivement je me suis fais mes journées
du patrimoine à moi tout seul c'était
cool j'espère que les prochaines en 2010
ne vous laisserai pas les journées du
patrimoine c'était vraiment super puis
j'ai hâte d'être à ce soir pour voir
cette chine auront vraiment avec le
container où on a parlé de ta leurs
salaires des vraiment super et puis
happy birthday sam aussi une très belle
création d'alexis moity m'ont vraiment
un lieu incroyable un lieu de culture
fantastique qui méritait un beau coup de
jeune et vous lui avez donné sermon
superbe
s'il fallait résumer en 30 secondes pour
ce qu'ils nous prennent en cours de
route la sur france 3 ce matin et
pourquoi pas aussi en replay sur france
3 point fr et qui tombe sur cette image
là l'entrée de l'espace des arts de
chalon sur saône scène nationale
complètement relifté vous l'antiqua
vicois en 30 secondes
je leur dis de devenir alors ils peuvent
venir
franchement d'une manière très cool
découvrir les spectacles ou boire un
verre ou visiter l'expo qui est ouverte
à tous ou simplement se poser prendre un
café ce sera possible dans quelques
temps parce qu'à le wifi qui est
disponible et à un moment donné cette
familiarité qu'on peut connaître par
exemple au centre beaubourg à paris
eh bien j'ai envie puisque l'espace des
arts c'est un lieu de communauté que ça
rassemble des gens qui sont des
passionnés de spectacle ou tout
simplement qui se dit voilà on va passer
un moment là parce qu'on est bien et de
vous à - philippe je me suis même laissé
dire que nous pourrions peut-être à
l'image de la tour eiffel monter au 9e
étage comme ça pour quelques moments
organisé ici dans l'espace des arts vrai
ou faux en deux secondes c'est
absolument vrai c'est un lieu magique et
ce sera possible
merci philippe obligé de prendre la
baguette magique et de faire disparaître
parce que autrement nous allons tous
tout simplement des 100 m merci aussi à
vous clément merci à vous tous d'avoir
été avec nous et merci à toutes les
équipes de france 3 qui ont travaillé
j'espère qu'au nous
ont donné envie de venir visiter ce lieu
unique en bourgogne franche comté qui
est l'espace des arts de chalon sur
saône scènes nationales merci philippe
encore une fois pour son accueil merci à
toutes les équipes qui ont fait un
boulot formidable ils sont tous là
partout j'espère vous retrouver lundi à
l'ats bonheur évidemment de très bonne
humeur lundi nous vous aiderons à
choisir votre avocat nos sciences et
faire le grand écart facial voyant
passer de tous les sujets a pas de
problème bon week-end à tous et profitez
bien de better ce grand moment à vivre à
l'espace des arts aviateurs
[Musique]